let's give a warm Hannity audience
welcome former V team Mike Pence
wow
vice president good to see you thank you
Sean
for the record when I came out I did not
get a standing ovation
um yes you did I did I actually did not
but this is what a great crowd right the
fun people thank you
let me let me ask you this question
first because it's news of the day yeah
and this has to do with Alvin Bragg and
the New York D.A and what they're trying
to do to president Trump uh and you
called it quote it feels like a
politically motivated or politically
charged prosecution here what did you
mean by that
well look I think
what we're witnessing is what I call the
criminalization of politics
I mean the truth is let me stipulate no
one's above the law but no one is below
the law and the American people are
tired of a two-tiered justice system in
this country
I believe
well
I mean you know we we saw the we saw the
politicization of the justice department
during the Trump Pence years we saw FBI
agents falsifying documents to pursue
the Russia hoax then we saw the whole
zielinski phone call business and and uh
and and it just hasn't stopped and here
you have uh here in New York City this
Manhattan D.A who literally campaigned
on going after one American you have an
attorney general in this state that
campaigned after going for going after
one American and let me say I know
nothing about the allegations I'm not
here to defend them and I know that
President Trump can defend himself but
the American people are tired of
politics playing a role in Justice and I
think tens of millions of Americans look
at what's happening in the Manhattan
DA's office and say enough is enough
we've got to end this political
prosecution of the president and end the
politics that's playing a role in our
justice system around the country
Kim Jordan is investigating whether or
not the FBI is politicized and the doj
is weaponized I wonder and I do not
believe at this point in history that we
have equal justice under the law or
equal application of our laws it breaks
my heart to say that but if we don't fix
it uh that takes away the heart of our
Constitution doesn't it well there's a
reason why
that statue outside of virtually every
courthouse in the country Lady Justice
is blind
and and the truth is we all deserve
equal treatment in the law and and it's
one of the reasons I you know I spoke
out on this over the weekend when I
first heard rumors of it I I am hopeful
uh that because the American people have
learned more about this I I'm hopeful
that the Manhattan D.A thinks better of
it I mean because the reality is a very
very bad week thankfully uh and I think
he's rethinking the whole thing yeah he
has to be this you've brought an awful
lot to light on that and I I know
everybody appreciates the job
to the American people
but I wanna
I just want to say this is bigger than
any one person right and and I think the
American people understand that that in
in this instance uh we we simply have
got to we've got to stand on the
principle that the law needs to be
equally approached you agree with every
person about we don't have equal justice
under the law for example nobody was
held accountable for lying on a fisa
application at the top of a fisa
application it says verified they used a
dirty Russian dossier paid for by
Hillary Clinton and it's unverifiable is
all false or the fact that the FBI was
working with big Tech in 2020 and they
were meeting with them once a week and
they were saying you might be a victim
of disinformation and it might be about
Joe Biden or Hunter Biden so the New
York Post breaks that story about a very
real laptop and they didn't report it
and they wouldn't even let people post
on it well I I think the suppression of
the story about Hunter Biden's laptop by
virtually every artery of the national
media was a disgrace and I've said so
um but let me say this this is bigger
than just this instance uh that I
honestly believe whether it's the FBI
going after a pro-life father standing
over the FBI a memorandum the targets
people going to school board meetings to
stand up for their kids interests in
their schools we just we just got to
make sure we just got to make sure that
we've taken the politics out of our
justice system at every level and and
let me also say you know the American
people are they're they're tired of a
two-tiered system of justice but they're
also tired of the drama
you know the justice department ought to
be and and local prosecutors ought to be
focused on putting bad guys in jail uh
in this city that is fraught with a
crime rate
and but the flip side of it is as I
travel all over the country Sean I have
to tell you this is not the stuff the
American people are talking about I mean
there are families that are hurting out
there
I mean I met I met a mother at a gas
station not long ago who told me that
she has to go to a food bank twice a
week because gasoline prices and grocery
prices have have dug into their family
budget heating and air conditioning
prices I'm telling you you know whether
it's gasoline prices the crisis at our
border whether it's inflation at a
40-year high literally Joe Biden has
weakened this country at home and abroad
and we've got to have change and we've
got to focus on those issues no matter
most of the American people and that's
where all focused 60 percent of the
American people living paycheck to
paycheck many people are tapping into
their pensions at a big loss to do so
some people are putting Bare Necessities
on a credit card this is happening in
America right now because of these
horrible economic and energy policies
people criticize you because you say I'm
proud of the four-year record that I had
with Donald Trump
I'm incredibly proud of the record of
the Trump Pence Administration
stronger and more prosperous than ever
before and this Administration has
systematically dismantled the progress
that we have made at home and abroad but
I have to tell you that as I said most
of the national media is obsessed with
this story
most of the national media is obsessed
with my old running mate but as I travel
around the country the American people
are deeply concerned about what's
happening in this economy they're deeply
concerned about their family budget
they're deeply concerned about whether
their children or grandchildren are
going to grow up in America with as many
opportunities as you and I had and and I
really do believe that it's it's
incumbent on us to stand firm to speak
plainly let our yes be yes and our no be
no when it comes to the equal treatment
of the law but I also believe that that
to to win back America in the months and
years ahead we've got to focus on what
the American people are focused on and
that is securing this country at home
and abroad and bringing back this
economy for Working Families
last year
I think
I don't think you guys got enough credit
for taking out solomoni I don't think he
got enough credit uh during the the
Trump Pence years there was a coalition
put together the U.S Israel the Saudis
historic Egypt Jordan and the Emirates
against Iranian hegemony and fighting
against a nuclear-armed Iran okay now we
have China I call it a new axis of Evil
with Russia including Iran that is
according to reports close to a nuclear
weapon and North Korea a new alliance
created and they want a new world order
now Joe Biden lets a balloon fly all
over the country and spy on us you know
you know Up Up and Away in our beautiful
balloon
but in all serious and then Russia takes
out one of our drones there has been no
consequence of a response nothing
right well let me let me just say with
regard to the America's place in the
world today
that there's a truism in history that
weakness arouses evil
and that disastrous withdrawal in
Afghanistan the capitulation literally
begging for the better part of two years
for Iran to re-enter the Iran nuclear
deal the the capitulating on nordstream
2 to Russia without securing any concern
while killing off Keystone I I believe
shutting down energy in this country I
believe that that has sent a message of
weakness around the world it is
emboldened the enemies of Freedom the
answer is we have to produce American
strength and that begins
I say your favorite question for last
yeah
a lot of speculation you're going to run
for president in 2024. we're uh where
are you in that process well Karen and I
have been taking the matter to prayer
we're a family that believes in prayer
and I know you do and we've been
traveling around the country listening
by the way today's with a few New
Yorkers that are normal that you can
mention God it's okay
by the way
if in New York you mentioned God in the
public school you get arrested but
that's another story go ahead but I I
would tell you we're getting closer to a
decision we've gotten a lot of
encouragement around the country
and you know our our thought on this has
less to do with us
less to do with my my son as a Marine
Corps captain my son-in-law is a Navy
Captain has it has more to do with the
fact I think this country's in a lot of
trouble so do I and I know what the
media is obsessed about on any given day
but the truth the matter is we have to
produce leadership in this country that
will take our country back to the
policies that left us stronger and more
prosperous in the Trump Pence years and
if we can play a part in that gentleman
Mike Pence
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else